sehen wir bilder aus stockholm der
schwedischen hauptstadt belebte plätze
viel leben auf den straßen warum dürfen
die das und wir nicht ist das gefährlich
oder nicht haben die schweden doch recht
damit dass man einfach weitermachen
sollte all das wollen wir herausfinden
und besprechen mit guter weise live aus
schweden
wie leben die schweden gerade das wir
sehen uns auf den bildern es ist viel
los genießt man dort jetzt also einfach
den frühling
also habe man muss dazu sagen ich bin in
göteborg ich bin an der westküste
schwedens
hier gibt es noch nicht so viele
infizierte und todesopfer wie wie in
stockholm in der hauptstadt ist es
tatsächlich am schlimmsten aber ja die
infektionsraten steigen auch hier und
genauso leider auch die todesopfer
zahlen ja also wie man sieht ich bin
hier in einem randbezirk von göteburg
wunderschönes wetter 19 grad das ist für
schwedische verhältnisse quasi ohne
hochsommerlich und hier ist es ja sehr
lange und sehr lange dunkel im jahr und
auch sehr kalt deswegen genießen die
schweden das jetzt natürlich auch gerne
draußen zu sitzen
also wenn man jetzt mal schaut ist es
jetzt nicht so dass die cafés und bars
restaurants überfüllt sind es war auch
in der innenstadt heute allerdings muss
das jetzt auch nicht unbedingt daran
liegen dass das die leute abstand halten
wollen wegen der pandemie sondern halt
einfach ja quasi nicht nicht so voll ist
zu der zeit
das ist sicherlich am wochenende anders
wenn es gutes wetter ist oder auch zum
after work
ja aber es hat natürlich auch
auswirkungen auf die leute dass es nicht
so dass die leute einfach in ihrem
alltag normal weiter nachgehen
ein großteil der arbeitenden bevölkerung
ist in kurzarbeit
es gab auch schon viele kündigungen
schon schon mehr als zur finanzkrise
2008 ja und es ist schon spürbar und
auch hier aber bereiten sich jetzt die
krankenhäuser darauf vor dass es auch
hierbei mehrere fälle auf den
intensivstationen geben wird haben sie
ja gesagt es gibt auch steigende zahlen
in den infektionen und auch den
todesfällen gibt es
so auch viele schweden dies kritisieren
wie locker man in ihrem land mit dieser
krise umgeht und erfordern dass man
strengere regeln hat weil das jetzt
gerade gefährlich ist also unter unter
so privatleuten an sich habe ich habe
ich diese haltung nicht wahrnehmen
können bis jetzt also ich hatte eine
starke erkältung mit fieber und
schüttelfrost und war dann einige tage
gesund und bin dann halt aber zum schutz
anderer mit gesichtsmaske in die
apotheke oder in den supermarkt gegangen
und habe halt wirklich so erschreckte
blicke bemerkt um mich herum also ich
sehe wirklich niemanden mit
gesichtsmaske heute ein sanitäter der
einen krankenwagen gestiegen ist
ansonsten überhaupt nicht aber es gibt
natürlich auch hier verhältnismäßig
viele todesopfer also ich meine wenn man
diese an dem ihn nicht rein ganz ich geh
jetzt keine monologe aber wenn die leute
halt nicht dazu gezwungen werden sich zu
isolieren ist es natürlich klar dass das
die infektion sich weiter ausbreitet und
die gibt es mittlerweile knapp 2000
todesopfer laut stand heute nachmittag
und wenn man das vergleicht mit
deutschen zahlen an die schwedische
bevölkerung liegt ungefähr bei 10,3
millionen menschen und in deutschland
haben wir acht mal so viele mehr als
achtmal so viele menschen und nicht
nicht mehr doppelt so viele todesopfer
vielen dank guter weise live aus
schweden für diese einschätzung zu
dieser situation dort